voters in the u.s have been casting
ballots for either joe biden or donald
trump
but to be president they'll need to win
the electoral college
not necessarily the most votes across
the u.s
so how does the electoral college work
that college is made up of 538 electors
they're people chosen from each state
the number of electors each state gets
depends on how many members of congress
it has
so california has 55 but vermont only
has three
now whether a state's electors are
republican or democrat
depends on which candidate gets the most
votes in that state
so let's take california as an example
say a majority of californians vote for
joe biden
he wins the popular vote there in that
case all of california's 55 electors
are going to be democrats it's winner
takes all no matter how small the
majority
those 55 democrat electors are then
obliged to vote for biden
to become president trump or biden has
to get at least 270 electoral votes
that's just over half
so it's the electoral college that
matters not winning the popular vote
and 2016 is a good example of that
back then some said clinton's chances of
winning were high
but she didn't win that's because while
clinton got more votes overall
what's called the popular vote she lost
the electoral college
in almost every presidential election
the
winner of the national popular vote
has also won the electoral college what
happened in 2016
was extremely rare donald trump beat
hillary clinton in michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin by a total of just under
80 000 votes
but he ended up getting all 46 electoral
votes in those three states
it helped him cross the 270 mark to win
even though hillary clinton got more
votes overall
nearly 3 million more here's the other
thing to watch out for
some states are expected to be easy wins
for trump or biden
but the tight races will be in what are
called battleground states or the vote
could go either way
and together they make up a lot of
electoral votes that could tip the
outcome
keep an eye out for more videos from the
start here team on al jazeera's facebook
and instagram stories
and our twitter feed where we'll bring
you updates throughout election night
[Music]